thank you for joining our live audience
as with every episode I would love to
take your questions live during the show
that's the whole point of this live show
um and welcome to hiking cast V2 this is
the second episode of our new live show
about open source AI
so I think I really appreciate you
coming on at this time uh we'll so
hiking cast what is this thing we wanted
to be a cross between a podcast and a
webinar we want to talk about the latest
and the greatest development in our
beautiful world of Open Source Ai and we
also want you to walk away Having
learned something practical that you can
apply in your work so in each episode
we'll walk you through Hands-On demos
and show you demos
and so we want to make this uh
interesting fun uh short and sweet
hopefully so we won't use the full hour
today we really want to try to keep the
show at 45 minutes last time we we said
we could try and we can try it we'll try
it yeah let's see let's do better let's
do 45 minutes people have a weekend to
go to and of course we're excited to to
take your questions so yeah ask them uh
while we're speaking we'll get to them
when we have the time
um I'm Jeff pudier I'm on the product
team here at hiking face and my
co-conspirators and fellow casters the
cast of the hugging cast The Heroes of
the demos Philip Schmidt and Julian Simo
and today I'm really excited to bring on
to the show our first special guest
Leandro from Vera co-author of the
Transformers book and also today the
lead of big code at hugging face and we
want to learn all about star coder the
latest code large language model but the
before we start I think we have a little
bit of celebrating uh to do we achieved
two super super exciting uh Milestones
uh last week that we want to share with
you and for that I have a prop
oh no
that's the problem all right so that's
embarrassing that's embarrassing it's so
80s
so today this week we're celebrating a
hundred thousand stars uh for the
Transformers Library
um yes if I had a little sound effects
with the Applause like that's when it
would come on
um it's really amazing to see
Transformers be the second project in
history uh to reach that milestone for
for machine learning congratulations to
all all the community uh for all the
contributions that came to uh to the
library and to celebrate this our team
um the the Transformers team put
together a really cool uh um page on the
Transformers GitHub to surface a hundred
projects a hundred awesome projects that
were built with Transformers uh so from
GPT for all uh you get a mines DB link
chain in their parlay I sentence
Transformers of course spiral NLP stenca
alpacalora I'm not gonna name the them
all but all of them are really awesome
awesome projects from the community
built upon Transformers so thank you
community uh to help us reach that
history milestone
second thing we want to celebrate uh we
celebrated last week is
um The Hub reached 200 000 open uh open
source models freely accessible uh
models on the Hub this is an amazing
Milestone and so yes thank you community
for continuing uh to share uh with uh
with everybody the results of of your
work so 200 000 models free and
accessible to use on the hiking phase
Hub today
congratulations uh Hub team
all right so that was uh that was the
congratulations bit
um
now I want to turn on the news uh so on
the news front we also had a couple of
very cool announcements uh since our
last uh show uh the first one is uh our
partnership with IBM so I don't know if
you've seen it uh we have a little uh
URL for you guys uh to check it out uh
check out the blog post on it if you
want to put that on uh on the on the
ticker
so on the blog post you'll learn all
about our partnership around Watson X
Watson X is a new platform built on open
source to do safe machine learning
within the Enterprise and so it's super
cool for us uh to be able to contribute
uh to that something that we're working
right now with IBM and that will be
really really powerful for uh for the
Enterprise so the two worlds are
colliding and it's very very exciting
and then another announcement that was
just this week at the Microsoft build
conference we announced a native
integration of the hiking face Hub
within the new Azure AI studio so you
can go in there and find a model catalog
that's called the hagenface Hub with
like a thousand models that you can
deploy in place it's a couple it's a
couple clicks and we really love to to
know what you think about the experience
is brand new so there's lots for us to
to to improve and add an ad to it
all right so that's for the news
um and now I want to turn it to uh to
Leandro our special guest uh today thank
you so much Leandro for uh for joining
us
over the past couple weeks like I've
kept talking about uh star coder and
I've been really really excited about
this model release
um and one narrative that I've been I've
been saying and I want to know if you
think that it's correct is that uh star
coder in a way changes the The Narrative
um that I've seen over the past six
months where the open source Community
we're sort of working together
feverishly to catch up on like black box
uh proprietary
models closed Source models and we're
quickly catching up uh with those models
and I feel like with star coder we're
flipping the narrative where actually
the open source model in many respects
is better than the proprietary closed
Source models that came before it right
you had you have open AI codecs you have
AWS code Whisperer you have GitHub
copilot all these things
um so I wonder like in your opinion like
is that a fair characterization and like
in what ways is star coder better than
those proprietary models
sure yeah I mean Stark weather is really
exciting
um we try to measure how good start
coder is like across many domains just
like one thing people are usually
interested in is so like what's its Pure
Performance right so we try to to
Benchmark it on standard code benchmarks
and it seems to be either outperforming
or matching
um
codex
um a copilot we don't know exactly the
the models that are powering co-pilot we
have some guesses and the way it looks
like Star coder is like on par or better
on some tasks
I mean in my opinion the the true power
of of star coder is not it's your
performance but also that it's open
which will allow people to do two things
one they can host it wherever they want
they can do whatever they want with it
they can have it locally
um a lot of companies uh can't use
copilot because it's like sending code
to do some remote place and code is
usually like one of the most guarded
like IP inside a company
but uh and the other thing is that if
you open source a very powerful base
model the community will quickly adapt
it uh to all sorts of use cases and
build cool things with it and I think
that's something that we saw quite a lot
with like stable diffusion and also
llama versus like as soon as there's
like a very strong base model
um the community will take it from there
and build so many cool things uh that
like a single team never could come up
with
thank you so much
um and
another thing that was super exciting
for me uh about uh not just star quarter
but generally uh the B code project
is the work around the data set and You
released a blog post recently showing in
full detail the work that went into
deduplicating data and there was a lot
of data I think over a trillion tokens
from 80 different programming languages
I was excited about the fact that you
guys had from the get go and opt out
mechanism so that developers can say hey
don't put my GitHub project into your
training data and I was also excited
about the fact that you guys only pulled
data from permissive licenses so as a
business like I'm not gonna run into the
risk that there's some code completions
out there in my codebase that come from
data that was not meant to be integrated
into commercial applications so can you
tell me a little bit about like how the
big code as an organization function and
made those decisions uh as it relates to
the data set
sure so big code is is an open research
collaboration so in general anyone who
is interested in building code lens they
can join and contribute
um it's led by hugging face and service
now so we kind of sponsored the compute
and the resources to actually train
those models but we want to take like
everyone along with the right to because
we think like if you want to build like
trust and transparency in this system
you want to do it in the open so
everybody can see what we're doing I
think there have been lots of discussion
what kind of data I went into copilot or
codex and also gfd3 or four nobody
really knows what's in there so you
don't really know whether you should use
the the model if it was like ethically
or responsibly sourced and so we try to
do these things in the open
uh I would say like we spent probably 60
80 percent of the time on the data set
rather on training models we found
pretty early that like you can get the
most boosts by making a better data set
rather than iterating on like fancy and
model architectures and for the model
architectures we mainly focused on the
things that we thought would be useful
and make the the model more performant
and easier to deploy but we spend like
lots of effort on the data set from like
as you said starting with very strong
near duplication we ran some ablations
figuring out like how should you filter
um a data set for code there are many
ideas that were around like should you
look at like how many comments are in a
code file and say like if it's only
comments or no comments that's maybe bad
so figure finds like the middle or
should we look at GitHub stars and then
they consider code that had at least a
few stars
um we found like GitHub stars is like a
bad idea that's the only thing that
really hurt the all the other
handcrafted rules that we came up with
for for high quality code data they
didn't really work much or didn't make a
significant difference the thing that
always made a difference is
deduplication so we decided after the
management experiments that's the way to
go and just focus on that so we had a
six terabyte data set originally we
selected some languages most popular
programming languages but also by trying
to include like some some domains that
maybe are interested in also using Code
models for example like people that use
match lab or Mathematica that were maybe
more like in in the Sciences or SPS or
like statistics
um
and then we kind of like filtered it
down to I think two three hundred
gigabytes so like most of the data I
already threw out of the out of the
window which is like a sad thing you
started like a big file of data and in
the end everything melts away uh but we
found out was actually better than
training on a lot of data that was of
like mediocre quality
um in fact one thing that I always find
a little bit surprising is like
it's better to de-duplicate and then
train more epochs rather than less
deduplication and only train one Epoch
so if you if you get rid of a lot of
like the duplicates or later the wickets
it doesn't hurt you if you train for a
few epochs actually
did you train star coder on like
multiple epochs or like was it like one
Epoch like equal to one trillion tokens
no I think we had 250 billion tokens
roughly in the training data set so I
think we ran four or five epochs okay
for the training yeah and if you look at
like the the progress you see like it
doesn't like stagnate after one Epoch
it's just like goes still up which is
quite nice
and do you think that's related since
like the data set is already quite huge
so like that you go through like the
same samples multiple times it's like
not leading the model to overfit or
whether you think it does it like it
comes from that it's okay to run like
multiple ebooks because I think like the
chinchilla paper or like the previous
research rather suggested to only train
for one epoch
yeah I think we internally some some
people have how you face random
experiments to see when does it start to
hurt when you train multiple epochs and
what they empirically found is like
roughly five epochs or so is fine after
that you're better off if you have more
data
um I think the reason why strongly need
to duplicate duplicating is better and
then run multiple epoches because you
kind of get rid of the natural
distribution of duplicates for example
in code probably 80 of your code are
like boring config files and I don't
know things unit tests that are very
similar but if you run near lubrication
for like a certain type of config you
only will have it once and if you train
five epochs you're going to see it five
times and before if you don't do nearly
lubrication maybe you have that file
like 50 000 times in in some form and
then if you run five epochs you're gonna
see it like a quarter of a million times
so that that's where it's really hurting
you can help um I must better understand
what isn't near duplication without
going into the technical details so how
could I explain it to my mom for example
like what it is
sure I mean the simplest thing you can
imagine is maybe you have a form and the
that form has a template where it's like
name I don't know your address and so on
and like 90 of the form is always the
same but like the things that you fill
out those are the things that are
changing and and nearly duplicate is
something very like most of the text is
the same but only like a few uh Small
Things changes and that's happening very
often in code where you have like
boilerplate code that you just copy
paste maybe you adapt one value but it's
like if you look is it equal it's not
equal but if you if you look at like
what's the overlap the overlap is maybe
very significant
so so I guess like the difference to
exact duplication or to like to
duplication what we know from like
regular human understanding is that we
have like Snippets or sequences which
are pretty close to each other and then
we remove them right yes exactly it's
like you you look at like how much of a
document overlaps with another document
exact deduplication is like the whole
document is exactly the same and nearly
duplication is maybe 90 95 of a document
is the same
foreign
there was like lots of python in the
training data there were also like lots
of notebooks in there uh I know there's
like a reinforcement learning from Human
feedback uh version uh Star Chat that
came after it
um so like what were surprising things
about the star coder model or star Star
Chat model that came from from all that
training data
yeah they were like a few surprising
things
um the reason why we included Jupiter
notebooks is because because we found
they're like surprisingly are not maybe
surprisingly but they're very high
quality data where you have a lot of
tutorials with lots of text not only
about programming but also about like
physics or electrical engineering like
you have this circuit now compute I
don't know some properties and then use
some code to do it and another
interesting thing you have is like the
output so the model can learn what a
piece of code would produce because the
cell outputs are still present in the
notebook and we did some small
experiments and you can use the model
kind of as a python interpreter right
like you presented a piece of code and
say like what's the output of that code
and we will try to to generate it
doesn't always work but uh sometimes so
that's that's a fun thing
maybe that's the most surprising thing
was we we did train it on like a little
kind of like conversational data mostly
on in terms of like GitHub issues that
were in the pre-training data as well
where like people discuss issues about
code
and um when we we had like a first
checkpoint of the model one thing we
tried to do is like anthropic release
the a long time ago or another long time
of it like a while ago uh a prompt they
call it the HHH prompt which is just
like lots of examples of conversations
and they found if you prompt the model
with all these conversations usually if
the model is good enough you can then
chat with it and we found that actually
also works with star coder so without
any fine tuning
um or instruction tuning or rlhf just
giving it a prompt with lots of examples
of um of coding questions and answers
and it's like things like that you can
then start to talk to the model which is
like when we did that the first time
that was very magical I think it's like
you have a code model but suddenly you
can also talk
wow that's amazing thank you so much
Leandro we promised everyone we're gonna
make it 45 minutes let's see if we do it
it was really amazing to talk to you
thanks for telling us about star coder
check it out on the big code
organization at hugging face on
hikingface.com thanks so much Leandro
thanks for having me it was a blast
awesome next session all right
um all right and now I want to turn our
attention to Transformers agents and
tools and Transformers agents and tools
was built by the Transformers team as
the boldest release yet of Transformers
so in a nutshell you can use a large
language model as an agent that's going
to break down your problem into smaller
problem and I think something super
exciting is that you can use any of
those 200 and thousand free and
accessible models or your own private
models as Transformers tools so to tell
you more about it how it works
Philly please take it away and I think
you need to zoom in a little bit because
I can't really make it yeah yeah so
um that that's currently the
Transformers as Jeff mentioned has now
agents and tools that's so like the the
first like release of the whole ancient
uh domain I would say for Transformers
Nation as Jeff mentioned is a large
language model which generates an output
which is then uh executed so we are
basically we are going to show it to you
in a second but we are asking the model
uh to do something like caption the
following image and what our agent then
does is it generates python code which
will then be executed and uses a tool
and the tool could be anything you could
really imagine we already built quite a
lot of tools for like the typical
um pipeline use cases so that you have
models for image captioning for text
classification for translation those can
be all be used as tools but you can also
write custom tools to do whatever you
want to for example like very a database
to
um do a Google web search to I don't
know get creative and even execute maybe
a JavaScript snippet and that's done by
tools so we have agents as like the
brain which is a large language model
and then we have tools as use case
specific models or executions for doing
a certain thing and a tool always has a
description and that is then used by the
agent to know what to do and then like
the code uh what it's going to to
execute
and the Transformers agents
documentation works you exactly through
what it is so like the first example we
have here is that our agent wants or
we're asking our agent to capture the
image and we have the image provided as
input variable or we could also ask the
the agent to to read something out
loudly and the cool part here is that
you can connect a concatenate though so
you could have a real jet interface
where you start with generating an image
then asking then asking maybe to like
what is on the image and then like
getting a response back okay we see uh a
beaver swimming in the water and then
you could say okay but please make sure
that the Bieber is not swimming in the
water it's on a tree and then let the
agent regenerate the whole new image
basically
um
yes and what we are going to do now is
we really like look into really using it
and the documentation let me quickly go
back links a call up notebook at the
beginning and this color called up
notebook allows you to
try out and use agents and tools and
what is super cool about it is that you
don't need to rely on open AI or large
property large language models so I can
face agents and tools work
locally and work on premise or in
private environments and currently of
course we support uh open AI large
language models but we you can also use
star coder as Leandro mentioned and also
the open Assistant model and we are
going to use star coder and we we
quickly heard from Leandro why we can
use dark coder probably most likely
because they train it on Jupiter
notebooks and stock order can now
generate code based on on input
and the notebook basically installs
first Transformers version to make sure
we have the latest version can you then
zoom in a little bit sorry thank you
um and then we have um we can select our
agent we want to use and depending on
the agent uh you use you either need to
provide an API key or a hanging face
token since the agents um are
um currently all like accessible in the
notebook through an API call so if you
want to run the whole thing in your
environment you need enough compute to
run the agent for Star coder it's a 15
billion parameter model for the open
Assistant one it's a 30 billion power
meter model plus all of the tools you
want to use but of course tools can also
be available through remote apis meaning
that you could have like different
models deployed and then let the agent
requests all of them
and then we can use our agent and here
we are going to generate an image of a
boat in the water and what is super cool
you can see what really happens behind
the scenes so
the code generated by the agent is then
automatically executed so we asked our
our agent hey I want to generate an
image for a boat in the water and then
the agent understands this prompt and
generates okay what could be the python
code for it to execute it based on a
fuel short prompt we provide and based
on the description and information from
the tool
and here we get a board
um it's not swimming in the water
but we can regenerate again and that
that's all that happens and the the
model used to to generate our images is
now running inside the collab notebook
and of course can be changed currently
the default model for the image
generation tool I think is the runway
stable diffusion model and but you can
like adjust it to your needs so if you
are building an agent system in-house
and you have your own like let's say
classification model for your support
request you could imagine building a
conversational chat agent for your
support coming in and then have your own
classification models trained on your
customer support data which classifies
okay what type of support requests do
you have and then you can basically use
the agent to request the tool to your
classifier to understand okay I'm having
a email verification
request the model is executed then you
can like return back to or like execute
a second tool okay if it's that case the
customer needs to like go to XYZ or
something and then like have the
customer chat with your agent and the
agent uses your internal tools which
could request your database which could
also request of course models you
customly trained
and then like the The Notebook basically
walks you through a lot of cool examples
on how you can use tools here we use our
boat image and ask the agent to caption
the image and again we can see okay uh
what it is going to do so
um the agent thinks basically I will use
the following tool image captioner to
generate the caption for the image and
then it generates the code and then that
this code is executed so always be
careful about which tools you use
because it executes basically remote
code so it's not that we are calling an
API this is fully code that is executed
at the end so always make sure that the
tools you use and provide to your agent
are safe and secure
super cool and uh well first like
there's a great comment from Juan Carlos
we say would be nice have a community
event to add more tools to the agents I
couldn't agree more one of the great
things about Transformers tools and
agents is the extensibility like how
easy it is to create a new tool and push
that to the hub so you can use it with
your agents and I think a question that
a lot of people are asking and uh here
uh asks if on behalf of everybody which
is like hey everybody knows about link
chain like in terms of uh breaking down
problems with agents Chain of Thought
Etc it's like a very exciting project
and we've built lots of Integrations
within face so like how is Transformers
agents and tools different uh from
LinkedIn and like when should people
think about using its versus Link Chain
yeah that's a great question so LinkedIn
is really amazing and awesome if you
want to work with API llm so most of the
features you currently see in link chain
four agents or the chains there that are
normally always tested with big
proprietary llms so all of the agents
you see powered by LinkedIn are normally
running uh the open AI models or the
anthropic models which makes it then
difficult if you adjust your link chain
project to use an open source model most
likely the prompts and how it is
structured internally is not going to
work with those open source models and
with Transformers agents and tools it's
basically built for open source and for
the models so the idea behind
Transformers agents and tools is okay
you can use it with open source models
and agents but you can also combine both
you could create a tool which then uses
link chain or you could use LinkedIn and
to then use a tool from Transformers
I wouldn't see them as like competitors
just where
probably you need to think about okay
what's my use case what do I want to
achieve if you have a use case where you
might want to read some kind of
documents then link chain is of course
stronger with all of their different
document loaders from S3 from I don't
know like Chira GitHub
basically anything available and If you
are allowed to use proper like apis like
for opmi a link chain also would
probably be better since they already
have built a lot of tooling around using
those those open EI models but if you
really want to build something
completely on the open source which
needs to run inside of your environment
where you want to really understand okay
what's the model used behind the scenes
what is trained on then probably
um hugging face agents is the better
solution and in if you want to combine
both
um you could use for example link chain
to create your Fusion prompts or to
create your chain and inside the chain
you could use a hugging face tool to I
don't know like translate a certain text
or use a model to classify some input
awesome
thanks so much Philip I'm super excited
about the modularity and one quick thing
to mention so we talked about those
those tools and some tools are
integrated into the Transformers Library
like image to text text to image text
classification question answering but
there's also a way to post and put your
tools on the hiking face Hub as create
your space which then can be used by
anyone so for example the team has built
something called text download which is
a space but also a tool and each tool
has a like a library or like a class
which inherits from the tool class and
then a call and each tool as we already
discussed earlier has a description okay
basically describing when the agent
should use the tool and then it has a
tool config and then you can load it
similar to models and data sets from The
Hub you can load tools from The Hub as
well so you can build a tool for the
community and then share it with your
friends or with ever who might be
interested so the awesome part here is
that it's way easier to distribute and
create like a platform similar for
models for tools so it's way easier to
get or create new ideas and then use
them in your applications
that's really really awesome thank you
so much for walking us through uh
Transformers agents and tools uh The
Boulders release yet uh for Transformers
I'm super excited to see what the
community will will build with it
um and on the uh on the business front I
I saw a lot of great great content uh
come from you Junior with this past past
couple weeks I know you've been all over
the place but somehow you managed to uh
to put out some videos from the the
Hilton series oh yes series and like a
couple things that I really want you to
uh to to dive a little bit deeper on is
uh one uh you ran a benchmark Benchmark
uh to compare uh sort of speeds uh you
were getting uh with uh AWS trainium
um versus GPU I would love for you to to
get give us a little bit of a download
there sure
um and then yeah anything else you want
to share with with the hiking Squad yeah
yeah so it's you know a hardware
optimization is uh is a very is a very
important topic for for customers those
Transformer models are awesome they get
more awesome every day but they're large
and you know training them fast and and
running inference at the proper speed is
is always a challenge
um and so we have those Hardware
Partnerships with with Intel and AWS and
a few more that will be announced at
some point
um and we've been working uh the two
things I want to mention and I shared my
screen I guess you you probably need to
put it on the excellent thank you very
much on the screen here the first thing
I want to mention is a really
interesting experiment that uh that
we've been working on with uh with Intel
so you know obviously Intel is building
CPUs they have this new generation of
xeons
called Sapphire Rapids and
um they're running all kinds of
um of experiments on optimizing large
language models for Intel CPUs right and
in this particular example they uh and
they describe everything in in the blog
post they apply a new quantization
technique
um which is called Smooth Quant it's
still relatively new
and uh and in a nutshell smooth Quant
does a much better job at quantizing
large language models than previous
techniques okay you can read all about
it in the in the post and they try
different models you know the opt models
from Facebook and alpaca vikuna
et cetera Etc and they report some
really really interesting improvements
and they also built a demo so obviously
a space demo where they use a 7 billion
MPT model
and and use it for chat applications so
let me let me ask a question maybe
um I was in Germany yesterday so let's
ask
um a question about that I was in
colonial right
Okay so
all right so ask a question and I get
some you know I get an answer and you
could say well what's the big deal right
there are hundreds of models who can do
this today
well I guess the big deal is this is
running on a single CPU this is fast yes
um yes let's let's follow up um
what is that is that like 10 tokens per
second
it is fast right so I mean it's faster
than you can read it which I guess is
enough right
um and so as as mentioned here this is
running on a single Intel CPU right
um and uh and the the magic here is
obviously the hardware acceleration
support in in those Sapphire Rapids chip
it's called AMX Advanced metrics
extensions you can read all about it and
and the fact that obviously quantizing
will accelerate shrink I guess compress
and shrink the model so this goes to
show you know um obviously gpus are
interesting and there's room for
everybody and there's clearly room for
CPU inference we've known that for NLP
for years but now it looks like we can
also run smart chat bots on single CPUs
which is from a cost perspective and
just a flexibility perspective is very
very interesting right wow that's really
really cool but like just to to hammer
down the point like yeah when you switch
from like a a GPU instance to being able
to use a Xeon Sapphire Rapids CPU that
there's like a huge cost difference like
what is it like 10x or yeah there is a
significant cost difference and um and
you know those instances are still in
preview on um on the Ws
um they actually became generally
available on Google Cloud a couple of
days ago so if you're using gcp you can
use those C3 instances and and start
doing the same and and yes and you know
it's just simpler to it's just simpler
to work with CPU instances right I mean
like for once
um GPU memory is not a problem anymore
because there is no GPU right so you
just load the model in memory you can
actually load multiple models on the
same machine so that I guess the
inference stack to me feels much simpler
and if you want to repurpose that server
you know to become a database server
then fine right it's it's a it's a fast
machine it's a fast CPU machine you can
use it for anything so um so I think
from again from a cost and flexibility
perspective this is super interesting
um so we're we know we have this Optimum
interlibrary that our colleague Ella is
is working on hi hello
amazing job
um and uh and so those that's muscon
technique uh is is going to be soon
available in uh in Optimum Intel you can
already do quantization but you know
Ella will keep adding more techniques
so that all that stuff is literally
going to be you know maybe one line of
code away or two and and you can do the
same right so that's for Intel super
happy about the partnership and and um
and to continue making friends you know
on on GPU obviously um
uh I I the second thing I want to call
out is uh you know we like uh AWS
trainium and AWS inferential two pretty
you know we love them right Philip I at
least Philip and myself love them I
think Jeff I love them all right we'll
love them then
um we think they're really cool chips
and we work hard with AWS to make
Transformers fast and of course we want
benchmarks right so I I did a YouTube
video about a week ago uh where I
compare AWS trainium versus the Nvidia
GPU and in fact the P3 instances on the
Ws and so a lot of folks jump at me and
say oh no that's not a fair comparison
and and I will I will take it to the
Grave it is a fair comparison because in
most AWS regions you can the only thing
you can grab is P3 instances and v100s
right
um I think uh p4s are only available in
seven out of 31 AWS regions and even in
those region I can testify it is very
very hard to grab of a100s the reason
why I have a hard time doing that a100
Benchmark is because I cannot get an
instance so I'll have to beg and get one
from somewhere else so you can go and
look at the the the video for for the
exact benchmarks I just want to in the
interest of time I just want to show you
the the results so I run three training
jobs uh pre-training language
pre-training with gpt2 token
classification with Bert large
and image classification with the vision
Transformer okay and I compare the
largest trainium instance with the
largest V100 instance on AWS and and you
can see you can literally see the the
results here right oh sorry that ah yeah
that last line here
um so from a training perspective a
training time perspective trainium is
roughly you know two to five times
faster than the largest V100 instance
and it's let's say 2.5 to 8 times
cheaper
so imagine that usually it's one or the
other right you can train more cost
effectively but it's going to be slower
right here you get faster training and
lower costs so you know what's not to
like I was I was going to ask you about
the money because that's that's really
what what I care about here yeah so yeah
that's that's important performance you
know cost performance is the really is
the thing you need to look at not just
costs not just performance cost
performance and in this case you get
improvements in both dimensions and I
think that's really that's really great
so again uh go go look at that stuff
I'll put the the link to the video in
the in the chat if you're interested and
uh and I'll give the the mic back to you
uh Jeff thank you so much Julia I think
I think we're technically achieving our
45 minute uh self-imposed goal here yeah
but of course like I'll linger around to
get some questions from uh from the
community
um if you have questions you want to ask
us like go ahead it's a great time right
now otherwise we'll we'll turn off the
show and uh and uh invite you for the
next one okay
um
I have a question from insub are there
anything you need to change the code to
run Havana chip and I think by Havana
chip you mean Habana so Habana uh offers
the Gowdy chipsters Habana Gaudi and uh
Gaudi 2 we do a lot of work with Habana
to make it super super easy for you so
you don't have to change your code too
much so earlier Julian showed you the
optimum Intel code base you can find it
on GitHub it's open source that's how
you can get all the acceleration that
we're building into specifically for
Intel chips uh earlier Julian showed you
how he ran the Benchmark for trainium
that was using the optimum neuron open
source package where we build all of
this stuff that makes it super easy for
you to use trainium and inferentia and
with Habana we built the optimum Habana
uh uh do you want to pop up the link
here for for people
it's like really a line code change uh
to be able to take advantage from the
acceleration of the Habana Gaudi uh
chips accelerators yeah and so you know
like in florentia it's one line as well
like I said uh to to compile uh to to
run Mars on trainium you just need to
replace the vanilla Transformers trainer
with the trainium trainer so that's it
one python import and for uh for
inferentia there's no chance at all you
just take the model export it for
inferential and load it there and so
people who don't know uh who don't know
the The Havana Gallery chips so Gaudi
one is available uh generally uh on AWS
on ec2 on sagemaker uh so you can use it
super super easily uh and Gaudi 2 uh is
uh is out there it's not yet uh on AWS I
hope it will be very very soon uh but uh
you can you can get it uh from uh from
Intel and and Habana and we've been
working to show you like the kind of
results that we've been able to achieve
with it so great question
[Music]
um
and Igor was asking like where can we
find more information on Intel based
speed Improvement so first off like
every time we ran we ran new uh
benchmarks and Analysis we try to share
that out to the community so if you go
on our blog and search for Intel or
ebana or trainium yeah you will find
like a lot of great resources yeah there
are quite a few posts on Intel yeah and
then of course as I said like go on our
GitHub you will find all of our open
source repositories where we walk you
through examples on how to use it and
what sort of results you can expect
foreign
is asking about is that Havana so it's
Habana
Havana but I like it uh is that a
benefit for training only
um so the you know the accelerator is a
general purpose accelerator Gowdy one
was really built uh for for training use
cases but with Gaudi 2 we're actually
getting great performance on inference
uh as well so you can think of coyote 2
I think as a general purpose accelerator
specifically for ML workloads yeah just
share the blog post uh this is a recent
one where we show 3x speed up on uh
Bloom Z I think on uh compared to uh to
a100s so that's a good one again go look
at for the blog good luck look at the
blog lots of Gowdy stuff lots of cranium
and inferential stuff lots of Intel I
mean we we keep you know feeling me and
and the team we keep posting stuff we're
in love with Hardware acceleration
everybody loves benchmarks so we're
Benchmark Geeks there's lots of content
all right and I guess to close the show
Daniel uh gave me a little bit of a of a
hand there uh so thank you very much
much everybody for joining we're also
looking forward to the next one
um we'll uh send you an email to remind
you when the next show is going to be
probably in three to four weeks
um thanks again for joining in this not
super not most convenient of times like
wherever you live it's Friday have a
great week I have to say it's my fault
it's my fault because I was traveling
it's not your fault NADA it was I
couldn't do it I mean it was either this
or literally do it do it on the train
station so it was it was not an option
right well I'm glad we did it and I'm
grateful for everybody uh for joining
have a great weekend if you're in the US
happy Memorial Day and see you soon
bye bye-bye bye